[Musique]
excusez-moi vous venez souvent vous vous
promenez ici jardin hélè Cadou oui je
viens souvent dans le jardin j'abite
juste à côté et vous savez qui est
Hélène Cadou non pas vraiment ah non non
je sais pas du tout qui c'est na vra
j'en ai entendu parler je savais le nom
de ce parc mais je ne sais pas plus que
ça bonjour monsieur vous connaissez
cette endroit ah pas du tout c'est le
jardin Hélène Cadou ça vous dit quelque
chose hlè cou pas plus je ne connais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus bonjour à toutes et tous et
bienvenue dans ce havre de paix en plein
cœur d'Orléan ce magnifique jardin qui
porte le nom d'Hélène Cadou femme de
lettre et
poétesse c'est en 1951 l'année du décès
de son mari qu'elle vient s'installer à
Orléan et y occupe le poste de BI
bibliothécaire
elle consacre une grande partie de sa
vie à la diffusion de l'œuvre de son
mari poète lui-même René Guy Cadou puis
hélène est vite emportée par la passion
de la poésie il faut revenir pas à pas
vers la seule fenêtre ouverte l'avenir
est là comme un enfant qui rit il reste
assez de jours pour guérir une forêt
assez d'arbre pour croire à l'aurore un
grand coup de ciel sur ta vie a fait le
monde pur comme un Dr gonflé par le vent
on ne s'étonne pas qu'en 1990 cette
grande dame de la poésie contemporaine
reçoivent le prix Verline et qu'en 2016
la ville d'Orléan rebâtise ce parc
jardin Hélène Cadou en hommage à cette
immense femme de
[Musique]
lettre pour nous confier les secrets de
cet écrain de verdure j'ai donné
rendez-vous à Anne bourgeois passionnée
du patrimoine d'histoire elle va nous
raconter quel est le lien qui existe
entre cette grande dame de la culture
qui a été Hélène Cadou et ce magnifique
jardin qui lui a été
[Musique]
dédié bonjour Anne bonjour Céline
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
d'Hélène Cadou et de ce magnifique
jardin n nous trouvons alors le jardin a
été inauguré en 2016 et on lui a donné
le nom de Hélène qui est une orléanaise
d'adoption elle a vécu plus de 30 ans
dans la ville et elle est assez méconnue
malheureusement elle a été l'assistante
de George bataille à la bibliothèque
d'Orléan qui était située alors à
l'hôtel du Panloup et elle s'est
beaucoup impliqué dans le développement
et la démocratisation de la culture dans
les villes et quel regard intime en tant
que femme vous posez sur les femmes
poétesses malheureusement la la poésie
c'est devenu un petit peu la part très
congrue de la littérature et donc les
femmes poétesses bon ont une voix encore
plus discrète c'est dommage que la
poésie sorte de notre vie quotidienne et
est-ce que vous nous feriez un petit
cadeau poétique en nous lisant quelques
vers de la poésie d'Hélène Cadou je sais
que tu m'as inventé que je suis née de
ton regard toi qui donnais la lumière
aux arbres mais depuis que tu m'as
quitté pour un sommeil qui te dévore je
m'applique à te redonner dans le nid
tremblant de mes mains une part de jour
assez douce pour t'obliger à vivre
encore mais voilà c'était le petit
bonheur du jour d'Hélène Cadou qui tombe
juste à point n'oubliez pas d'être
heureux des fleurs des cœurs des
couleurs du bonheur même pas
[Musique]
peur